13 février bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction voici
les principaux titres c'est l'une des
plus grandes grues d'Europe elle est
actuellement utilisée en Gard de
Versailles chantier pour installer une
passerelle de plusieurs centaines de
tonnes les images et les explications de
ce travail très minutieux nous parlerons
égal du parc de Toir la réouverture est
programmée ce samedi de nouveaux
arrivants de nouveaux espaces nous en
parlerons avec Paul de la Panouse
fondateur de l'établissement et puis
comme chaque vendredi l'essentiel de la
semaine élection départementale avec
l'annonce des candidatures pour le
scrutin de mars mais aussi mobilisation
pour obtenir des enseignants remplaçant
attrappe et lancement enfin d'une
campagne de sensibilisation au détecteur
de fumée dans le département des
ivelines l'une des plus grandes grues
d'Europe a donc été installée à
Versailles l'engin de 100 m de haut va
permettre de de déposer une passerelle
de 200 tonnes à la gare ferroviaire de
Versailles chantier un reportage de
Michel elmidoro et des images de Patrick
Jacques de
dixmud 100 m de haut 650 tonnes l'une
des grues les plus grandes d'Europe
vient d'être montée à Versailles
chantier son objectif installer une
passerelle dans le cadre de la
modernisation de la guerre versaillaise
le transport de la machine a nécessité
des moyens techniques importants elle
est arrivé en petit morceau elle est
arrivé avec 50 camions et poids lourd
d'Allemagne il a fallu donc organisé à
travers versaill des convois
exceptionnels on a été aidé par nos
collègues des forces de l'ordre la
police les motards pour acheminer ça on
l'a monté en 5 jours plein et donc
aujourd'hui on est en train de faire les
essais de levage auxquels vous allez
pouvoir assister et il faudra bien sûr 5
jours pour la démonter et la renvoyer je
crois dans le sud de la France la future
passerelle de la gare versaillaise pèse
plus de 200 tonnes et mesure 100 m de
long et 10 m de large la grue va
effectuer un travail d'or Fèvre où
l'erreur n'existe pas on s'imagine pas
mais cette passerelle métallique qui est
faite de pièces massiv elle a une
tolérance de pose sur les poteaux de 2
mm c'estd on a 24 poteaux qui ont été
tous alignés en visé laser et on va
venir poser délicatement avec précision
aux bons endroits aux bons appuis les
deux colis et avant de de pouvoir les
souder il y a des mini réglages de
planimité d'horizontalité et donc c'est
la précision c'est 2 mm l'opération
débute ce vendredi 13 février pour
réaliser ce chantier titanesque le
trafic des lignes nu et du RC sera coupé
entre 20 22h et 6h du matin ce weekend
et le weekend prochain la SNCF mettra en
place des bus de substitution pour les
usagers faut savoir que sur un
dispositif comme ça où on substitue de
manière significative Paris Brest on met
plus de 350 bus c'est 350 agents SNCF
mobilisé entre rambouillé et
Montparnasse pour prendre en charge tous
nos clients avec un effectif conséquent
sur la gare de 180 agents en 38 c'est
des rotations qui sont assurées par bus
c'est de l'accueil client c'est du en
fort aussi de la sûreté donc vraiment
c'est un gros dispositif pour SNCF pour
observer la mise en place de la
passerelle ce spectacle d'ingénierie
sera visible par les rives Rin en
nocturne depuis le passage des éangober
jusqu'à 1h du
matin on parle des élections
départementales puisqueà présent nous
allons nous focaliser sur l'essentiel de
la semaine le Parti communiste à travers
le Front de Gauche rejette clairement
l'idée d'une alliance avec les
socialistes les candidats sur dévoilé et
cette semaine témoigne du rapprochement
entamé ces derniers mois avec Europe
Écologie les vers Julien Ibor secrétaire
départemental du PCF c'est expliquer sur
ce plateau c'était jeudi soir voici un
extrait de son intervention nous on
souhaite le rassemblement le plus large
possible de la gauche mais sur des
contenus qui sont clairement
antiaustérité en rupture avec les
politiques qui sont menées aujourd'hui
par G pas aller vers le Parti socialiste
que vous de fait ça revient à ça même si
compris on renonce pas à avoir des
socialistes qui nous rejoignent qui
viennent avec nous sur des des
initiatives ou dans des élections c'est
possible aussi dans certains endroits
pctuellement ce serait des fondur dans
ces cas-là par rapport au Parti
socialiste et la ligne affichée oui je
sais pas ce que veut dire exactement le
terme frondeur je vois qu'il y en a qui
se reconnaissent plus ou moins dans dans
cette définition mais en tout cas ceux
qui refusent la politique aujourd'hui
d'austérité qui est menée en France avec
les conséquences dramatiques qu'on
connaît pour la pour la population donc
nous on veut le rassemblement le plus
large de la gauche et effectivement et
particulièrement sur CTIN ça se décline
plutôt sur des rassemblements avec
europécologie les Verts qui se situent
eux vraiment dans cette rupture
vis-à-vis de de l'ostérité on a on a
discuté des réunions avec europecologie
les Verts le Parti socialiste y compris
d'autres partis comme le Parti de Gauche
et d'autres et on a vu que c'était pas
que c'était pas possible y compris parce
que des fois les propositions
n'existaient même pas parce que dans tel
ou tel endroit le Parti socialiste ou
d'autres avait décidé de partir tout
seul et que que voilà donc il y avait
pas une une volonté de toute façon ni de
la part du Parti socialiste ni de la
part d'écologie les Verts ni de la part
du du Parti communiste de partir
ensemble partout voilà c'était quanton
par quanton qu'est-ce qui était possible
qu'est-ce qui n'était pas possible
politique toujours et ces élections
départementales le mouvement de Nicolas
du ponteignan sera bien présent dans les
Yvelines dans 8 des 21 quanton les
électeurs pourront choisir pour des
candidats debout la France debout la
France anciennement Debout la République
présente des candidats dans huit cantons
Fabien MTA pâtissier aujourd'hui
étudiant en histoire et Plaisirois
depuis toujours également conseiller
municipal élu sur la liste de la mre
joséine Colm berger il se présente pour
défendre trois thèmes l'éthique
politique euh une bonne gestion
financière de du département et le bon
sens afin de servir au mieux le le
bien-être des élus noirs ce qui m'a
donné envie de rejoindre Debout la
République enfin maintenant debout la
France c'est parce que j'ai enfin je
j'avais le sentiment que le pays était
mal géré depuis une quarantaine d'années
et que les partis de gouvernement
n'avaient pas réussi à apporter des
solutions adaptées à la situation et je
pense pas non plus que la la la
situation viendra des extrêmes il fera
campagne avec Pascal Michard gérante de
société à Plaisir autre binôme cette
fois sur le canton de saint-ciier
l'école Sylvia quantaloupi qui est de
toutes les campagnes politiques et
Christophe Pitel élu conseiller
municipal majoritaire à Villepreux ni
système ni extrême leur slogan de
campagne d nettoyer la politique on
essaie d'avoir des élus propres nouveaux
et qui traînent pas des casseroles
derrière eux parce que après on est
prisonnier soi-même de ses habitudes et
que au conseil général il y a des bah
c'est c'est le train train quoi ils sont
entre eux ils font toujours les mêmes
choses les mêmes subventions les mêmes
comport
avoir des des subventions qui soient
vraiment utilisé pour pour les les
associations et les intérêts des du
canton de saint-cire déjà pour un
premier pour un premier point et surtout
utiliser et pouvoir développer le
département comme il devrait l'être en
dehors du FN qui aujourd'hui est la
seule alternative qui est proposée par
le système contre l'UMP PS il y a une
autre solution qui est debout la France
et moi j'essaie de mener ce ce terrain
là ces candidats mèneront la campagne
avec comme ils disent les moyens du bord
il ne disposent pas des finances des
grands partis ils feront donc beaucoup
de tractag pour faire connaître le parti
de Nicolas du
pontaignan et puisque l'on parle de
politique n'oubliez pas l'bdo politique
proposé par nos confrères de radio
sensation dimanche à 18h Nicolas
kirilovit reçoit François degier le
maire de Guill en cour conseiller
général sortant en campagne pour le PS
sur le canton de Montini le Bretonneux
face notamment à Michel logier le maire
de Montini et président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de saint-qutin
on est sur l'enjeu des élections
départementales alors moi je suis
conseiller général sortant demain on
dira conseiller départemental ça sera le
nouveau mot mais c'est la même fonction
c'est celle qui consiste à représenter
les habitants d'un territoire en
l'occurrence Montini aiguille en cour au
niveau du département dans un
département qui a une majorité très à
droite c'est-à-dire que le seul argument
que j'entends de la part de Monsieur
logier c'est moi je ferai partie de
cette majorité actuellement il y a 2
tropcré à droite au Conseil Général de
droite et 11 de gauche sur les 39 voilà
mais vous avez entendu que le président
sortant monsieur Bédier grand ce qu'il
appelle le grand chlem alors le grand
schlem en matière de rugby moi j'adore
en matière de politique c'est la volonté
d'éradiquer toute opposition je dis
est-ce qu'on a besoin d'un conseil
départemental supplémentaire à la
majorité qui voudrait être hégémonique
et déjà extrêmement à droite où est-ce
qu'on a besoin d'une voie
libre d'une voix qui va dans le sens de
la justice sociale et qui rappelle ce
qu'est normalement le rôle d'un
département c'est ce que j'ai fait moi
pendant 7 ans avec un bilan que je
présenterai aux habitants maltraitance
utilisation abusive de la chambre
d'isolement dans de nombreux services
psychiatriques c'est ce que dénonce dans
le département une association la
Commission des Citoyens pour les Droits
de l'Homme elle vient d'organiser C
manifestations c'était également dans
l'actualité de cette semaine psychiatri
barbarie internement ça suffit dénoncer
les abus psychiatriques voil action qu'a
mené samedi la Commission des Citoyens
pour les Droits de l'Homme en
manifestant devant plusieurs centres
hospitaliers des ivelines dans le viseur
de l'association les mauvais traitements
infligés au malades ou encore des
procédures d'internement à la demande
d'un tiers appliqué de manière abusive
vous avez plus de 85 % des procédures
qui sont utilisées de cette façon donc
pour nous c'est inacceptable parce que
ce sont des milliers de personnes qui
sont hospitalisées dans le département
des des ivelines avec beaucoup moins de
garantie pour le patient parce que vous
avez qu'un seul certificat médical qui
est nécessaire li de de et vous avez
l'accord de la famille qui n'est pas
obligatoire et même la famille peut être
en désaccord avec la procédure
d'hospitalisation sous contrainte et le
psychiatre aura le dernier mot pour
procéder à l'internement de la personne
l'association dénonce l'excès de pouvoir
des psychiatres mais aussi le manque de
contrôle de la part des autorités depuis
2006 notamment à plaisir vous avez
aucune visite ni du préfet ni du
président du tribunal de grande instance
or ces autorités doivent visiter
l'hôpital au moins une fois par an pour
l'association les soins administrés au
mal malad sont également considérés
comme inadaptés vous savez quand
quelqu'un se fait hospitaliser sous
contrainte c'est quand même sont des
traitements très lourds qui lui sont
administrés avec des effets secondaires
dévastateurs avec une dépendance très
forte et vous avez aussi des mauvais
traitements vous avez aussi des
électrochocs he la sismothérapie j'ai
une belle sœur qui vient d'être internée
en hôpital psychiatrique on la met sous
psychotrope elle elle est devenue un
vrai légume alors que bon évidemment
elle avait des problème psychologique
c'est un fait mais les médicaments qu'on
lui donne ne l'aident pas bien au
contraire bien au contraire elle est
encore plus dépressive qu'elle ne
l'était avant des appels à témoins ont
été lancés avec une distribution de
tract pour recueillir des témoignages
mais aussi redonner de la valeur à la
parole des
malades trouver un professeur remplaçant
dans une école se révèle toujours un
exercice périlleux il est encore plus
visiblement attrappe l'association des
parents d'élèves indépendants dans la
commune vient de s'exprimer sur ce sujet
mercredi une dizaine de parents
trapistes mobilisé ce mercredi matin
pour demander plus de profess remplaçant
dans les écoles de la commune on n pas
de remplaçant quand les professeurs sont
absents on manque de remplaçant de
manière c'est répétitive donc il y a un
ralbol parmi les parents dans l'école de
mes enfants oui il y a ce problème là
qui est récurrent on a une classe
notamment qui a pas eu d'enseignant
pendant 4 5 semaines et ça a des
incidences de toute manière sur toutes
les classes puisque du coup il y a les
enfants qui n'ont pas d'enseignants qui
sont répartis dans les classes qui se
retrouvent surchargés on est à 40 élèves
parfois quand il y a des enseignants
absents une pétition a été signée pour
revoir notamment le mode d'attribution
des professeurs remplaçant les parents
d'élèves ont été reçus en mairie pour
une première réunion ces parents qui
sont venus chercher le soutien de la
municipalité on a fait les démarches
auprès de de l'inspection académique he
c'est Jean Marie qui a fait ça dans le
cadre de son mandat et et eux ils ont
exprimé un besoin oui il y a trop
d'absence il y a vraiment vraiment trop
d'absence sur la ville de trappe hein
c'est on peut pas être en secteur
d'éducation prioritaire on ne peut pas
dire que il faut que les services
publics se réinvestissent dans dans des
dans des secteurs urbains fragiles et
cetera puis en même temps avoir une
vingtaine d'instituteur absents depuis
longtemps une nouvelle réunion est
prévue le 20 mars avec les services
académiques une situation bien connue le
nouveau directeur inois réagissait
d'ailleurs ce mardi soir sur notre
plateau actuellement on a effectivement
une une difficulté objective nous avons
remobilisé des enseignants pour le
premier degré de manière à à assurer les
remplacements qui sont dus quitte à
prendre il faut bien le dire avec regret
hein sur la notre capacité de de
remplacement des professeurs qui partent
en formation les services académiques
sont en train d'identifier les
circonscription qui présente le plus de
difficultés en la matière afin d'opérer
dans le cadre de la préparation de la
rentrée prochaine un rééquilibrage sur
le manque de professeur
remplaçant éducation toujours et le
nouveau responsable académique des
Yvelines en fonction depuis le début de
cette année 2015 était l'invité du
journal cette semaine mardi il s'est
exprimé notamment sur le nouveau plan
développé dans le le cadre du
harcèlement à l'école vous imaginez bien
qu'avec le recul qui est le mien depuis
un peu moins d'un d'un mois je je je
peux pas en parler très savemment
simplement ce que je sais c'est que
aujourd'hui on voit une montée en
puissance j'allais dire du du nombre de
signalements et et ça montre bien que le
travail qui est impulsé au niveau
national et repris au niveau du
département porte ses fruits on ne par
pas de rien puisqu'il y avait déjà des
systèmes d'alerte des un numéro vert qui
est utilisé et puis encore encore une
fois des des compétences qui sont
mobilisées au sein des inspections
académiques c'est le cas AG Guill en
cour avec une assistante sociale et une
équipe qui sont en capacité de répondre
d'abord à la demande que peuvent
formuler les chefs d'établissement et
les directeurs d'écoes à des situation
complexe pour aider à les dénouer mais
surtout à prendre en charge rapidement
et durablement les victimes de de ces
situations l'actualité cette semaine
c'est aussi le préfet des ivelines qui
était mardi présent à la caserne des
pompiers de Versailles il a lancé à
cette occasion la campagne sur les
détecteurs de fumée ces derniers seront
obligatoires vous le savez dans tous les
foyers français à partir du 8
mars
papa papa allez viens ma puce attends
mon doudou non on n pas le temps une loi
pour sauver des vies à partir du 8 mars
tous les foyers français devront être
équipés d'un détecteur de fumée Pierre
Morange député de la 6e circonscription
des est à l'origine de ce texte l'homme
politique s'est lancé dans ce combat
suite au décès d'une jeune fille de 16
ans dans un incendie à chavenet en 2002
madame bico en fait habitaé à saintnon
la Bretèche mais sa sa fille était avait
passé une soirée avec des amis en effet
à chavenet et elle m'a relassé raconé
cette histoire terrible les larmes aux
yeux avec une dignité une
émotion qui prenait la gorge
véritablement et pour le médecin le
maire du un village le père de famille
le parlementaireyant quelques lueurs en
matière de protection sanitaire et
sociale et ben bien évidemment je lui ai
proposé que nous nous battions ensemble
afin que de cette souffrance et bien
nous puissions et bien la mettre au
service de tous cette histoire n'est pas
un cas isolé en moyenne 350 personnes
perdent la vie chaque année dans un
incendie domestique en France dans les
ivelines 1 à 6 décès sont recensés par
an suite à l'inhalation de fumée toxique
dans 70 % des cas les accidents se
produise la nuit il y a des grandes
idées qui font qu'on estime toujours que
ça va se passer chez les autres et qu'on
aura le temps de réagir au cas où et en
fait malheureusement notre expérience
montre que c'est rarement le cas et que
des drames à la fois matériels mais
surtout humains sont des conséquences de
cette manque de préparation un détecteur
de fumée coûte en moyenne entre 15 et 25
€ un seul avertisseur peut permettre
d'assurer la sécurité d'un appartement
si votre habitation comprend plusieurs
étages il est conseillé d'installer un
détecteur à chaque palier ne peut
installer qu'un seul détecteur de fumée
puisque c'est le minimum imposé par la
loi il faut privilégier le couloir qui
dessert les chambres en général
puisqu'on pourra réveiller en même temps
plusieurs personnes dans dans le moment
de la journée où elles sont plus
fragiles les plus exposées parce
qu'elles dorment dans la cuisine ce
qu'on conseille par contre c'est un
détecteur de chaleur qui lui sonnera
quand la
température de la pièce sera supérieure
au fonctionnement et à l'attente normale
qu'on peut avoir dans ce genre de pièce
objectif annoncé par les soldats du feu
réduit par de le nombre de morts dans
les incendies en France dans les
prochaines
années et puis enfin un mot de sport
pour conclure cette édition 6 milliards
d'euros c'est le montant du budget
initial pour organiser les Jeux
olympiques de 2024 dans la capitale un
cout relativement faible qui pourrait
séduire la mer de Paris anniealgo et
dans le rapport du Comité français du
sport international présenté jeudi aux
élus on apprenait que le vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline pourrait bien
faire partie des sites retenus le site
d'ailleurs inauguré l'année dernière
devait servir au Joo de 2012 mais
Londres souvenez-vous l'avait emporté
ceci marquerait donc une belle revanche
le vélodrome qui va accueillir dans
quelques jours les mondiaux du cyclisme
sur piste c'est la fin de ce journal nos
excuses si vous attendiez l'intervention
du compte Paul de la Panouse pour
évoquer la réouverture du parc de toiri
retenu à la dernière minute pour des
raisons personnelles il n'a pas pu nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau ce n'est bien
évidemment que partie remise je vous
souhaite un excellent weekend sur
TVfil